In this lesson, we're going to talk about light mass and light maps.
So let's get started.
So again, we're in the baking scenario here if you were to use it.
Now again, sometimes you may use it, sometimes you may not, but mostly Lumen does a really
good job.
But say you didn't want some of the noise that came with Lumen, you can definitely take
this approach for certain shots or for a particular game if you wanted to.
It's still fully supported.
Now how it works is, and I notice I have here it says kicking it old school, is kind of
our offline GI renderer.
Its performance cost is virtually zero at runtime.
The building process gets longer as your scene becomes more complex.
So you have to keep that in mind.
And also that your shadows won't be as realistic as they would using virtual shadow maps.
Because as we talked about in the first class, your shadows, the visual fidelity of those
shadows are determining on how close distance you are to that object and puts it in a cache
and it will call upon it when needed.
Unfortunately, when it comes to light mass, when it builds your shadows, it's going to
be kind of an all or nothing scenario where it's going to bake it and they're all going
to share space on a particular type of texture map that's actually put into our scene and
almost like a blanket specifically for static objects.
So you can adjust light mass settings at the actor level or more globally in the world
settings panel.
And we're going to talk about this in just a second.
And again, you can see the options here where it says shadow maps and virtual shadow maps.
Again, virtual shadow maps for Lumen, shadow maps for baked lighting.
I do want to make a note here on the bottom here.
It says Nanite is made for Lumen and not really for Unreal light mass baking.
You can use it, but you could slow things down if your geometry is really complicated.
So make sure you turn Nanite off when baking and that you are using shadow maps for baking
or you will crash or take forever to bake non-Nanite.
Just keep that in mind.
GPU light baking can be used if Nanite is needed.
Now also want to make the statement here.
If you have non-Nanite objects and they're in your scene, you're using Lumen, it's better
to try to keep that within Lumen.
Keep it Nanite if you can.
And using virtual shadow maps.
It's like the three Musketeers, which I kind of mentioned in the first class.
Lumen, Nanite and virtual shadow maps all play nice together and it's best to work in those
scenarios.
So let's look at some settings in light mass that can get you started in the right direction.
Now this is found under the world settings.
Let me point you in the right direction.
Then we're going to go back to the slide.
So in Unreal you go to your world settings and again you'll see where we have our light
mass settings here.
And there are several different things and several approaches you can take.
But in the beginning I have to really emphasize start low and then go high.
Some people when they are working with baking will crank all these up really high at first
and throw everything at it.
But Unreal you want to be very deterministic because you're working in a real time setting.
The same goes with Lumen.
So always start low then go high and test your settings, your computer, what it can
handle as you go and also in relation to your scene.
Let's go back to the slides and look at some of these settings that I have pointed out
for you.
So you'll see initially we have static lighting level scale set to one.
This is your light mass detail.
We also have number of indirect sky bounces, three to ten, and it actually helps handle
scene brightness.
We have indirect lighting quality, one to four.
This increases your final gather rate count and reduces artifacts that may occur.
You also have indirect lighting smoothness.
You have a one to a 1.3.
This blurs indirect lighting results, reducing noise.
So that can be very helpful.
We also have compressed light maps.
You want to disable this if you want a bit more realism in your scene.
You'll see in my example here that it has it checked on.
But try to turn that off if you're going to be using a baking scenario to get a bit better
with your shadows so that they don't look, I guess the best way to put it is they look
very edgy.
They look very almost like a video, an old Atari video game.
So you start to get like those blocky edges.
We don't want that.
We want a smooth transition into our shadows if we're using baking.
So you also want to have, which I mentioned earlier, is a light mass importance volume.
This is very important to put into your scene, particularly if you're going to have a terrain.
This allows Unreal to know what your priority area is and what you're focusing on when you
decide to do rendering.
So the volume that focuses the detail in direct lighting, photons coming from the light mass.
Use it to determine the area of gameplay or area of importance.
This is very important for your visuals.
It is a detailed GI.
It restricts that area.
So it's honoring your settings and the area outside of the importance volume will only
get the low quality GI once bounce.
So you're making it so that it's honoring what you've put in and you're telling Unreal,
Hey, prioritize this and use my settings that I have in place.
So light map UVs, why are they important?
So when it comes to baking, these UVs allow Unreal to place self shadowing on this object
and also shadow relationships to other objects in the scene, particularly if they are static.
Now, self shadowing still does occur for objects that are being lit, say they're moving.
Things are being lit by stationary light because a stationary light is made to be able to handle
moving objects, but there's only four overlapping at a time, which I mentioned earlier.
So to create believable self shadowing is why they're in place and object casted shadows.
It can be important so you can make your own UV light maps.
You can make a secondary copy your UVs in a your DCC and you can make one with proper
padding and put it in there as a secondary UV channel and Unreal will recognize that.
And you can also tell Unreal to look at that if there's a problem with that.
You want to make sure if you do do that, there's no overlapping, there's adequate padding,
and you also hide those seams.
It also can be auto-generated by Unreal, and I've never really had a problem with it auto-generated.
It does a really good job, but there may be times where you specifically, if you are using baking,
you want to make your own UVs because you want the shadows to look really good on this
hero object and you want to make sure that it's you're in full control.
But again, we have a solution for this.
This is a heavy workflow.
You can use lumen.
The only thing with lumen is you need to watch out for the noise that may occur.
So light map UVs made with two light sources.
You can see some samples here.
Light is baked to a light map texture and you'll see it bakes it in almost like I said
before, like an AO occlusion is self shadowing.
It's baked right into the texture.
The base color texture here, light map is multiplied on top of that base texture.
So you can kind of see the logic and the process of what Unreal does.
The end result relies entirely on a texture for displaying lighting.
So again, we talked about solver quality.
So don't forget about this.
When you're working initially in your scene, you may want preview and you might want to
try medium or high, but production is going to give you the best results of the
bounces that you need and want.
Here's a link for more additional resources on light mass and global illumination.
That's it with this one.
In the next video, we're going to talk about reflection baking, how to work with
these reflection probes and assets that we have in Unreal to be able to get things
in the right direction.
Thanks again.
.